ich hab da mal ne frage was ist hier
bitte los deutschland hat gleich zwei
regierungen aber keiner davon regiert
ampel und groko streiten wer mehr schuld
ist und so stolpert die nation wieder in
den corona winter wieder dinner for one
butler über den tigerkopf
immerhin haben wir jetzt ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz die epidemische
lage läuft aus ironischerweise mitten in
einer epidemischen lage und
flächendeckende schließung sind bald
ausgeschlossen also bis sie doch kommen
natürlich ist ja klar ich finde die
menschen bräuchten wirklich mehr
ansprache sie brauchen orientierung
trotzdem war gestern im bundestag als
das gesetz beschlossen wurde nur die
zweite reihe am mikro dort kein wort von
scholz kein wort von merkel ja das war
noch ihre stärkste szene der abgang so
leute bin was ich bin weg duldung was
gibt's heute eigentlich in der kantine
gut muss ich dazu sagen am abend hat
sich die kanzlerin dann schon zu wort
gemeldet nach dem comeback der
legendären bund länder konferenz
zitat merkel jetzt ist die absolute zeit
des handelns nach meiner uhr war die
eigentlich etwas früher aber
der sache richtig verbindliche
schwellenwerte für 2g wurden unter
anderem beschlossen + 3g am arbeitsplatz
und dann hat olaf scholz ja noch so eine
art flammenden appell gehalten wir
müssen das gemeinsam hinbekommen und wir
werden das auch gemeinsam hinbekommen
uns in dieser situation
nach einem weg zu begeben wie wir es
hinbekommen
wir müssen gemeinsam einen weg
hinbekommen habe ich verstanden sie
hörten unseren nächsten kanzler ob das
reicht was da gestern beschlossen wurde
darf sehr wohl bezweifelt werden
tatsächlich hätten aber bestimmte
ministerpräsidenten in ihren ländern
längst härtere maßnahmen ergreifen
können wenn ich bestimmte sage meine ich
natürlich markus söder ist ja klar der
jetzt von morgens bis abends auf die
ampel schimpft während in seinem bayern
die inzidenz durch die decke gehen ja ja
mit ihnen
viele wissen das gar nicht in der
bayerischen sprache gibt es tatsächlich
kein einziges wort für selbstkritik alle
sind schuld alle sind schuld nur
zögerlich als nächstes ist er
wahrscheinlich die virologen hätten es
verbockt was es ist ja sehr
beeindruckend dass nahezu alle biologen
epidemiologen und wissenschaftler auch
die wirkung dieser neuen welle in ihrer
wucht und geschwindigkeit nicht richtig
eingeschätzt
es ist ja sehr beeindruckend wie man so
eine scheiße erzählen kann ohne rot zu
werden alle relevanten wissenschaftler
haben sie gewarnt christian drosten oder
wie seine fans ihn ein drost radar muss
er prophezeit schon am zweiten september
kontakt beschränkungen und jetzt kommt
es für alle das robert koch institut das
ärger er hat im juli ziemlich exakt
vorhergesagt wie bitter der herbst wird
wenn wir nichts an der impfquote machen
jetzt ist es möglicherweise selbst für
2g schon zu spät im spätsommer hätten
wir spätestens was machen müssen aber da
war wohl keine ahnung das wetter zu
schön
mindestens das buch dann hätte man da
planen müssen seit gestern heißt es
jetzt wir wollen bis jahresende
27 millionen deutsche boostern im moment
auch fast ohne im
kommt ich will jetzt mal eine schöne
nachricht
es ist denkbar so sagen jedenfalls
wissen wissenschaftler das ende des
jahres mit einem impfstoff auch gegen
kinder gerechnet werden kann
gut das wäre natürlich ein traum muss
ich
etwas wobei die kinder unser geringstes
problem sind freunde angesichts von 14%
ungeimpften in der altersgruppe 60
allein in bayern steigt die zahl der
intensivpatienten jede woche um rund 30
prozent aber da hatte wolfgang kubicki
der alte fdp kämpfe jetzt die rettende
idee erfordert zitat endlich die
intensivbetten reserve zu aktivieren ja
geile idee wolle wirklich geile idee wir
haben nicht zu wenig möbel wir haben zu
wenig pflege wie ist meine zeitung
kubicki nicht selbst das deutsche
gesundheitssystem kann wegen corona
irgendwann kollabieren und hängen wir
leider alle mit drin meine damen und
herren in manchen regionen warten zum
beispiel schlaganfall patienten zwei
stunden auf ein intensiv bett das heißt
jeder von uns jeder von uns muss jetzt
unbedingt vermeiden ins krankenhaus zu
müssen wir entlasten unser
pflegepersonal und alle machen mit gehen
sie gerade als älterer mensch nur noch
mit passender schutzkleidung die treppe
runter jeder oberschenkelhalsbruch
weniger
bitte vermeiden sie gerade jetzt aus
geiz ihre neue hängelampen selber
anzuschließen
zeit sie zu reanimieren video und am
allerwichtigsten übrigens auch nach
gronau beim smoothie machen niemals
einzelne banalem stücke aus dem mix
erwischen mach mit bei der russische
reaktion
keiner muss mehr ins krankenhaus außer
wegen kohle haben
ja sehr gute aktion können sie alles in
ruhe noch mal nachlesen in dem
wunderbaren buch der 100 jährige der aus
dem fenster fiel und verstarb weil die
intensivstation mit ungeimpften corona
patient überlastet worden sehr lange
titel gestern war in sachsen die
inzidenz der vollständig geimpften
65,8 die der ungeimpften
2003 ja da sind kontakt beschränkung für
alle wohl kaum noch zu vermeiden
irgendwann in österreich ist am montag
lockdown für alle ja nach nur wenigen
tagen locker und für ungeimpfte was zwar
ein paar österreicher an die spitze
getrieben hat stichwort schnitzel panik
aber
offensichtlich nicht genug obendrein
kommt am ersten februar heute verkündet
und das ist ein hammer in österreich die
allgemeine impfpflicht
in einer demokratie ziemlich heftig sein
aber die sind halt verzweifelt während
unverbesserliche ossis weiter auf sagen
wir mal alternative corona therapien
setzen
gleichzeitig ist in mehreren regionen
ein entwurmung mittel für pferde
ausverkauf gegner schlucken dass im
glauben sich damit vor dem virus
schützen zu können auch der chef der
rechten fpö herbert kickl hat empfohlen
ja sie lachen aber das schlimm wissen
was das heißt österreichische pferde
können bald nicht mehr vernünftig
entlohnt werden
weil die doofen menschen ihre wurmkur
fressen kommen irgendwas ist immer
irgendwas ist immer
ab montag ab montag in österreich
lockdown für alle ich habe mich gefragt
wie die österreicher ihren lockdown nur
für ungeimpfte überhaupt kontrollieren
wollen man kann ja immer sagen als
spaziergänger bei ikea einkaufen oder
besuche meine familie im keller was man
halt
was man halt in österreich so sagt weiß
ich doch nicht hier neuer blockbuster
[Musik]
die ausgangssperre für ungeimpfte sitzt
anna dem morgen unterwegs
ist wieso ungeheuer einfach nur der
weltmeister noch nicht über spätfolgen
der muss jetzt leider erschießen besser
ist
ja
das stimmt so aber auch hier in
deutschland wird es für die ungeimpften
schrittweise ungemütlich in bus und bahn
zum beispiel die ampel will im öpnv audi
3g regel durchsetzt mindestens mit
stichprobe war gut im fernverkehr der
bahn könnte das mit viel glück
vielleicht funktionieren aber im
nahverkehr viel spaß die kölner verkehrs
betriebe informieren fahrscheine
kontrollieren ein wichtiger job und
bisher eine der beliebtesten berufe in
deutschland morgen
doch jetzt kommen schwere zeiten auf uns
zu wir sollen 13 bussen und bahnen
kontrollieren und werden dabei auch auf
einige aggressive impfgegner treffen
dies erfordert fingerspitzengefühl
sensibilität und eine top vorbereitung
[Musik]
so leute wir trainieren jetzt den
ernstfall 3g kontrolle im berufsverkehr
ich gehe rein ziehe übertrieben oder
vorschläge auch ne
entscheidend ist die richtige ansprache
souverän aber nicht zu autoritär
keine so
das ist hier geliehene sie weiß ich
nicht die mich auf den sack
immer wieder so ein der vorgelegt jetzt
dann haben schon in seiner banane war
dann glaubt dass er keine maske tragen
muss und bist ja ein ganz schlauer
ich bin geimpft aber
leider mein ticket vergessen ich idiot
was machen wir denn jetzt
ja es war zwar geht halt nicht regeln
sind regeln ich hab noch ein problem im
öffentlichen nahverkehr halten muss sie
viel zu oft an und manche leute fahren
eben nur ein bis zwei stationen mit
ich habe sie noch nicht vor falls ja
dann etwas noch nicht gesehen
[Musik]
seine damen und herren wir
erleben gerade gemeinsam ein
hochspannendes phänomen je mehr leute in
einem land deutsch sprechen desto
schlechter ist offenbar die impfquote
wirklich es kann wie jetzt deutschland
österreich und die schweiz stehen im
westeuropäischen vergleich auffällig
mies da die rechte schlagzeile aus der
financial times nein danke der
resistance to commit 19 bands in german
speaking europe jetzt muss man sich
schon von engländern beleidigen lassen
das hat doch nichts mit der deutschen
sprache zu tun welches sind die gebiete
in italien wo ist schlecht los wo die
infektionszahlen hochgehen und das ist
gerade der deutschsprachige bereich von
der südtirol ach du scheiße
liegt etwa doch an unseren umlauten
meine so viel im skepsis obwohl man sein
risiko auf einer intensivstation zu
landen um rund 90 prozent senkt das muss
ja irgendwelche gründe haben vielleicht
tatsächlich kulturelle oder historische
klarer fall für
[Musik]
holte show history mit albrecht humboldt
liebe zuschauer was stimmt nicht mit uns
der deutschsprachige raum neulich noch
corona musterschüler ist plötzlich so
was wie die lepra kolonie europas dabei
war das adjektiv deutsch mal ein synonym
für rational wir standen für fakten für
vernunft heute sind wir dass hier was
ist corona für sie die ich trage einen
mund nasen bedeckung die die forderung
erfüllt unser grundrecht
was ist das denn ich kämpfe mich jeden
tag mit einer schönen dosis bier zum
beispiel
also ich lebte regelmäßig von das nennt
man alkoholiker aber ungeimpft
und da kaiser wilhelm
1874 gab es die erste reichweite
impfpflicht für kinder vorher sind jedes
jahr 70.000 kinder an puppen gestorben
nachher nicht mehr trotzdem riesen
widerstand und weil der impfstoff aus
kohle gewonnen wurde gab es karikaturen
die davor warnten dass man durch die
impfung zur kuh wird
ist dass der mal passiert
nur selten
in deutschland gab es immer wieder im
skeptische bewegungen eine besonders
skurrile gruppe nannte sich zum beispiel
die nazis im nazi deutschland gilt
vielen impfen als jüdische erfindung
körperliche ertüchtigung und gesunde
lebensweise sollten ausreichen
krankheiten abzuwehren
eigentlich ein wunder dass wir den krieg
verloren haben bei der vielen natürlich
gelogen hat anderes beispiel für
impfskepsis deutsche milieus die
anthroposophen auch die fanden impfen
schon immer unnatürlich und haben ihre
ganz eigene medizin rudolf steiner sagt
zum beispiel kein witz wer sich in einem
früheren leben nicht genug für die
stirne also astronomie interessiert hat
leidet in diesem leben unter
bindegewebsschwäche mein gott was der
kunde man das erklärt alles
und so haben wir eben bis heute milieus
die entweder dem staat nicht trauen oder
der wissenschaft und wenn jetzt
wissenschaft versagen dieser impfstoff
ist sicher glauben sie den
wenn es mehrere wissenschaftler
unabhängig voneinander sagen würden das
ist total sicher
dann natürlich aber das sagen die doch
eigentlich
[Musik]
doch
schon
1869 wurden in deutschland die ersten
impfgegner organisation gegründet und
zwar in achtung stuttgart und leipzig
nein ja vielleicht ist da ja doch
irgendwas im trinkwasser oder nur so als
hypothese es liegt am dialekt vielleicht
macht das irgendwas mit dem gehirn wenn
man schwäbisch oder sächsisch reden
das ist ja geradezu sexismus was sie da
erzählen völlig bescheuert auch in
sachsen sind die im skeptiker eine
minderheit und das hat auch nichts mit
kultur zu tun ich sag mal was in
frankreich gab es noch letzten herbst
vielmehr impfskepsis als bei uns in
deutschland und dann hatte marco im
gegensatz zu unseren politikern die eier
schon im juli 2 g einzuführen zack die
impfquote das ist das ganze geheimnis
es liegt gar nicht am dialekt
gänseleber
gebärmutter 120 mikrogramm quecksilber
und seinem mikrochip
vielleicht nichts doch am dialekt
einrichtung wolf vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt haye